it seems to me beyond doubt that Judaism
is the most important intellectual
development in Western history for two
reasons one having to do with the
aesthetic and spiritual and the other
having to do with the ethical if I begin
with ethical and moral issues Judaism
invented the idea of mankind as an
entity so we see striking differences
between ancient Israeli literature and
Greek literature let's say in the first
thousand years of the 1st millennium BC
there is a word in Greek that has no
equivalent in Hebrew namely barbarian
barbarian meaning somebody who babbles a
Greek word meaning someone who babbles
who doesn't speak Greek who is foreign
who is culturally inferior by definition
and a very little interest not a not
only different but but boring Judaism
meanwhile insofar as it developed the
idea of a single God which was a
revolutionary and bizarre idea at the
time first emerges 3,000 some odd years
ago I figured that if there were really
only one God in the world he had to be
everybody's God everybody should have
the right to say this is my God must
have that right and then if you look at
who the community the faithful are in
principle is to everybody so Judaism has
the idea that ethical laws moral rules
and strictures apply to everybody not
that everybody has a sort of liability
to carry them out there was stricter
requirements of Jews or Israelis and
there are people in general Judaism it's
never been a proselytizing religion
doesn't really care the matter of fact
is indifferent about whether people
become Jews or join the Jewish community
but is very clear on what the basic
moral obligations of mankind are with
respect to respect for life respect for
justice kindness to animals a familial
what should I say is sexual fidelity and
and refraining from sexual crimes these
are the so-called seven laws the sons of
noah meaning that they apply to
everybody so without going into a
lengthy disquisition Judaism has the
idea that there is a simple moral code
which goes not only for the Israeli
people or the Israeli nation but it's
applicable to everybody and has the
revolutionary idea that not only is
there one God but there is essentially
one man when mankind the whole the whole
world so that on on festival occasions
at the Temple in Jerusalem sacrifices 70
sacrifices would be brought at certain
points it was thought that there were 70
nations in the world one for each nation
Judaism has an aesthetic and spiritual
side also of course Judaism is obsessed
with imagery one often finds its
stereotypes are either basically right
or exactly wrong I rarely sort of in
between Judaism is often described as
being hostile imagery but we know that
can't be right because the the Hebrew
Bible under law is Western literature
the Hebrew poetry the poetry the psalms
of the prophets in the book of Job is
the basis of Western literature Hebrew
prose narrative is the basis of Western
Western narrative there is no such thing
as great poetry without imagery the
ideas absurd there's no such thing as
great writing that isn't vivid and
vibrant and that means based on images
and we find in fact that the imagery of
the Bible is the imagery that recurs
through our Western literature in
Western art from split open red sea to
handwriting on the wall to the chariot
of fire these are images that are not
only painted in the in in the developing
tradition of medieval art and Western
realist painting but the recur in
Western literature of all languages down
to this afternoon so for both these
reasons Judaism has has a commanding
role in the creation
Minh the creation of the culture and
civilization that we've occupied for
several thousand years and especially so
with the emergence of the idea of the
liberal nation the liberal modern nation
which is sort of a joint invention of
the United States and of Great Britain
in the in the 17th century in the 18th
century these were Christian nations but
the Christianity of early America and of
Britain in the Elizabethan and and
especially the age of the civil wars and
Cromwell was what is often called
Hebraic Christianity or old testament
Christianity it was a profoundly Hebrew
inspired sort of Christianity not that
people thought of themselves as Jews
because they did not but both the early
the United States and early Britain
repeatedly referred to themselves as the
new Israel and the idea of freedom
Liberty emerges in the United States on
the basis of the story of the Exodus the
biblical verse let my people go which is
repeated many times by Moses to Pharaoh
becomes fundamental in American history
not only when religious zealots who were
persecuted in England emigrate in the
17th century to the United States but
when the United States declares its own
independence and freedom as a nation
during the Civil War when the north
becomes gradually resolved under
President Lincoln to free the slaves and
in the civil rights movement of the 60s
and late 50s to 60s again so the nation
of freedom the the notion of freedom the
notion of the quality which is derived
by the the founders of English and
American liberalism from the opening of
the Bible which says all men are created
in God's image therefore you're not
allowed to make distinctions on the
basis of of race color creed all men
being in God's image are to be treated
justly and fairly Abraham Lincoln put
that most concisely and interestingly
the idea of democracy to if you read the
early literature of the United States
developing the idea of modern democracy
in the 1600s especially in New England
and in Virginia to some extent
verses are quoted constantly not only
the ones in which Moses sets up what is
described as a Jewish Commonwealth he's
told to essentially let each tribe
furnish its own leaders tell Moses who
is leading me but it's also the case
that the Hebrew Bible is is a an
aggressively anti-monarchy book there
are vivid denunciations in the other
idea of a king the rights of Kings and
absolute king prophets in the Bible
confront Kings or order them in the name
of God to be fair to to be Justin to be
honorable and in fact Israel is told
that if it had any sense it wouldn't
have a king to begin with so in lots of
ways and this is something that used to
be well known the last couple of
generations in Western culture I would
say since the second world war have been
secularizing generations in which we
looked
we've been much more apt to look ancient
Greece than ancient Israel but as a
matter of historical records it's easy
to trace these ideas also in the
philosophy of the English enlightenment
it's easy to open a book of Locke and
notice that he keeps quoting the Bible
or Hobbes or Selden or other others of
the English philosophers who who
provides for the intellectual
counterweight to the active and
pragmatic liberalism of the of the
founding fathers